le déménagement du ministère de
l'économie et des finances à bercy
montré du doigt par le rapport annuel de
la cour des comptes d'une évaluation de
trois milliards et demi en 82 on est
aujourd'hui à 7 milliards et demi pour
ce déménagement très coûteux la cour des
comptes épingle le financement du projet
mais aussi le système informatique et
même la décoration et le mobilier martin
thibault
bercy un projet grandiose cinq bâtiments
6000 fonctionnaires 260 mille mètres
carrés de surface une réalisation qui
aura coûté 7 milliards et demi alors que
les premières estimations étaient de 1
milliard et demi
comment de tels dépassements ont-ils été
possible la cour des comptes accuse le
calendrier était trop serré 50 seulement
pour réaliser les études et la
construction irréalistes
des 82 ou 83 on savait qu'il fallait au
moins trois nuits
et puis il ya eu trois immeubles il a
fallu de 2,2 et la construction de deux
immeubles supplémentaires en 84 le
chantier est arrêté lorsqu'il le
redémarre deux ans plus tard décision
est prise de faire du ministère des
finances la vitrine du savoir faire
français les aménagements n'est plus
sophistiqués sont installés on prend le
parti du tout informatique du tout
bureautique enfin mobilier de bureau
décoration racines et installation d'un
embarcadère et de vedettes fluviales
pour transporter rapidement les
ministres mais qui ne serviront pas à
chef de gonfler la facture pierre
bérégovoy a voulu jouer l'efficacité
maximum une efficacité aujourd'hui
discutée car tous les équipements ne
sont pas utilisés les ministres des
finances de l'industrie du budget ont
emménagé en 1989
mais déjà ils sont à l'étroit ainsi
d'après la cour des comptes le grand
comptable de la nation n'a pas su donner
l'exemple d'une gestion au plus serré de
la construction de sa propre maison